لموسكو احتياجات عسكريه في صراعها مع
اوكرانيا ولب يونج يونج حاجه للخروج من
نفق ركود اقتصاديه كلمه السر في حل
الازمتين صفقات السلاح فوفقا لتقرير
لوكاله بلومبرج وجد الطرفين مخرجا لحل
ازماتهما بعقد المزيد من صفقات السلاح
التي توفر دخلا لكوريا المعزوله اقتصاديا
ومخزونا عسكريا لروسيا
وفقا لوكاله
بتنوع في مخزون سلاحها ملائم الاحتياجات
روسيا من بينها مدفعيه القرن العشرين
البدائيه الموجوده على الخطوط الاماميه
الروسيه امام اوكرانيا كما تمتلك ترسانه
للذخيره المدفعيه تحتوي على اكثر من
21.600 قطعه الى جانب قذائف مدفعيه 122
مليمتر
و152 ملليمتر جميعها تلاقي مراقبات موسكو
ما اقدرش
الى ان حجم الصفقات العسكريه بين موسكو
وبيونغ يونج قد تبلغ 320 مليون دولار
امريكي ما قد يضيفوا واحدا في المئه الى
اجمالي الناتج المحلي لكوريا الشماليه لكن
موسكو قد تفضل تقييم جوده بعض الاسلحه قبل
الالتزام بعمليه شراء كبيره
لم يعد نقل السلاح من كوريا الشماليه الى
روسيا يشكل هاجسا فلم تعد هناك حاجه
للمرور عبر دوله ثالثه ووفقا لموقع وفي
الثلثي 8 مستندا لصور عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه فان حركه التجاره عبر خط السكك
الحديديه الوحيد بينهما استئنفت التجاره
عليه اواخر العام الماضي دعم متبادل بين
موسكو وبيونغ يونغ لكنه تحت مجهري واشنطن
الرافضه له هناك ادله على ان مجموعه فاجنر
وهي منظمه شبه عسكريه تشارك بشده في جهود
السيطره على مدينه
ومعدات من كوريا الشماليه تحذير امريكي
تواكبه تحركات لها في كوريا الجنوبيه ما
قد يشعل الصراع بين دعم الكوريتين وفق
تصريح الخارجيه الروسيه نشر الاسلحه
النوويه الامريكيه في كوريا الجنوبيه
المحتمل سيؤدي الى عواقب غير حميده وستضطر
حاله تحققي هذا السيناريو الى اخذ الامر
في الاعتبار على صعيد تخطيطها الدفاعي
في الواجهه صراع روسي الاوكراني وفي
خلفيته تصعيد متواصل بين حلفاء كل جانب
كانت اخر حلقاته تحالف بيونغ يونغ موسكو
العسكري الاقتصادي في مواجهه التحالف
واشنط صول الضغط والرافدي لهذا التعاون
على السمان العربيه